en inde au milieu des bidonvilles de
calcutta capitale du bengale
jean paul ii est allé à la rencontre de
mère teresa prix nobel de la paix mais
aussi à la découverte de la misère la
plus absolue
le dénouement de milliers de femmes et
d'hommes recueillis par les religieuses
jean paul ii à calcutta
commentaire de philippe rochot jean paul
ii la calcutta
c'est le message de l'église à la
pauvreté pour la première fois un pape
dans cette capitale du bengale qui n'a
jamais réussi à faire vivre ces
centaines de milliers de réfugiés fuyant
les guerres de l'inde et les
catastrophes naturelles pour la première
fois aussi un patch et mère teresa
l'hommage rendu à l'oeuvre des
missionnaires de la charité dont
l'action a permis de sauver des milliers
de visuels et soulager les pauvres au
seuil de la mort c'est le plus beau jour
de ma vie a déclaré mr teresa à
l'intérieur du miroir jean paul de serre
plus longtemps si la d1000 deux malades
sur le point de mourir
il a aidé les missionnaires de la
charité à servir les repas
sa visite ce mouroir installé dans le
temple de cali restera sans doute le
temps fort de son voyage en oeuvre
auparavant jean paul ii s'était arrêtée
le temps d'une messe dans la petite
ville de ranchi au coeur d'une région
tribale
malgré l'hostilité d'extrémistes un vif
jean paul ii n'a pas hésité à dénoncer
le système des castes et en inde qui
réduisent en esclavage des millions de
vies le monde entier connaît sa frêle
silhouette drapé d'un sari blanc bordées
de bulles
son visage marqué de rideau si profonde
que son dévouement aux plus démunis mais
très peu connaissent le visage de la
jeune agnès 2nd g boyadjian fille
d'agriculteur né en 1910 en albanie où
elle vécut jusqu'à 18 ans avant de
rejoindre l'antre des soeurs de notre
dame de lorette en irlande début d'un
long voyage qui la mène dès l'année
suivante alors qu'elle n'est encore
qu'une jeune novice de 19 ans à calcutta
où on l'envoie enseigné la géographie et
le catéchisme aux jeunes filles de la
bonne société indienne calcutta où elle
prononce ses voeux en 1937 calcutta où
elle est bouleversée par la misère 1946
sera nièce demandent à quitter le
couvent pour aller vivre au coeur de la
ville avec les plus démunis
l'autorisation de sa hiérarchie arrive
deux ans plus tard
dès lors elle endosse le sari bleu et
blanc qu'elle ne quittera plus prend la
nationalité indienne choisi le nom de
thérèse par dévotion à la petite salle
de lisieux et après une succincte
formation médicale s'immerge dans la
pauvreté enfants orphelins lépreux
mourant soeur thérésa va vers tout ce
que les hôpitaux refusent le 7 octobre
1950 elle fonde la congrégation des
soeurs missionnaires de la charité
elle ouvre des dispensaires pour les
malades des orphelinats des centres
d'assistance aux mourants pour financer
les secours des pauvres elles frappent
aux portes des puissants jusqu en europe
et aux états unis de calcutta la
congrégation s'étend rapidement à
d'autres villes d'inde
puis à partir de 1965 au reste du monde
via caracas sans relâche
elle sollicite de l'argent et l'obtient
elle obtient aussi des prix tous les
prix possibles et imaginables en 1979 ce
sera le prix nobel de la paix elle a
déjà fondé 200 centres d'accueil est en
tout cas d'heure à ngon remercions dieu
vous enquête sur cette belle occasion
fait week end to gaza
brooklyn de proclamer tout 120 l esprit
d une fiche la joie de répandre la paix
en flagrant canada la joie de s'aimer
les uns les autres ou joy et la joie de
savoir que les plus pauvres d'entre les
pauvres sont tous à nos frères et nos
soeurs et stones 1981 le président
indien lui remet le joyau de l'inde
c'est la plus haute distinction civile
du pays 83 elle reçoit des mains
d'elisabeth de l'ordre du mérite
jean paul ii se lit d'une grande amitié
avec celle qui est désormais son
ambassadrice
mère teresa est doué de sens pratique
pour récolter des fonds mais on lui
reproche d'avoir parfois obtenu de
l'aide
deux personnages peu recommandables
comme le dictateur haïtien jean claude
duvalier
on critique aussi ses prises de position
car mère teresa n'hésite pas à monter au
tribune pour s'exprimer
l'avortement est un grand mal
rappelez vous la parole de jésus tout ce
que vous faites un bébé c'est à moi que
vous le faites nous refusons à la
considérer comme une sainte
pour nous c'est une politicienne de la
droite catholique qui est utilisé par
cette tendance
d'autres pensent que seul fonde son
action charitable cas partout le nombre
de portées contre elle ce qui compte
c'est que son action serve d'exemple
à ceux qui veulent poursuivre son chemin
mère teresa est sur tous les fronts en
elle ne craint pas de participer elle
même à l'évacuation des enfants
handicapés de beyrouth où la guerre fait
rage
sa vie est un incessant va et vient
entre le monde des puissants et celui
des exclus dans la maison du coeur pur
elle est simplement les hommes à mourir
pour que ceux qui ont vécu comme des
bêtes meurent comme des hommes dit-elle
en quatre décennies près de quarante
mille personnes sont décédées ici en
décembre 91 mère teresa participent à
une messe restaurant le culte catholique
en albanie toute pratique religieuse a
été abolie par décret en 1967 par le
pouvoir communiste
mère teresa n'est pas retourner dans son
pays natal depuis plus de 40 ans il lui
faut attendre la mort du dictateur
fondateur de l'albanie en 85 pour
renouer des contacts
elle ouvre aussi un orphelinat c'est le
premier établissement géré par un ordre
religieux depuis 45 en décembre 92 alors
que les affrontements entre hindous et
musulmans font rage en inde
mère teresa vient prier pour la paix au
mémorial du mahatma gandhi à new delhi
tout comme lui
mère teresa est très populaire pas
seulement dans la communauté chrétienne
indienne forte de 15 millions de fidèles
mais qui ne représentent pas plus de 2%
de la population
elle est aussi chère au coeur des
hindous qui lui voue un culte bien à
leur manière depuis 89 mère teresa
connaît une série de malaises cardiaques
on lui pose d'un stimulateur et on
l'opère à plusieurs reprises en 90 elle
a bien demandé à être remplacé à la tête
des missionnaires de la charité mais
l'ordre l'a reconduit comme supérieur
plus tard le pape refusera sa démission
à chaque fois mère teresa reprend son
bâton de pèlerin et ce malgré les crises
cardiaques compliqué de pneumonie et de
malaria en 96 années du 50e anniversaire
de l'ordre
elle exige même de quitter l'hôpital
pour ne pas rater les festivités à
partir de là on lui administre de
l'oxygène trois fois par jour
après 50 ans d'existence la congrégation
compte plus de 4000 membres répartis
dans 600 institutions dans plus de 120
pays
elle nourrit 500000 famille accueille
vingt mille enfants dans ces écoles et
soigne 90000 l'épreuve dans ces
cliniques mais la première mission de
l'ordre est avant tout religieuse et
mère teresa
mais beaucoup d'ardeur à vouloir
convertir les pauvres khaled ce que lui
reproche souvent les hindouistes
militants après avoir longtemps repoussé
l'échéance mère teresa passe enfin la
main en mars 97 c'est à dire six mois
avant sa mort
c'est une religieuse indienne un doute
converti au christianisme soeur nirmala
qui prend la tête de l'ordre danse et à
la surprise générale que la timide
religieuse de 62 ans issu d'une famille
de hautes castes a été élu par le siège
de l'ordre puis présenté au pape pour
assumer la difficile tâche de succéder à
une véritable icône
malgré sa fragile santé mère teresa a
effectué une tournée de neuf semaines en
europe avant de se rendre aux états unis
en juin
là le congrès américain lui décerne la
plus haute distinction la médaille d'or
pour son engagement en faveur des plus
pauvres
ce sera la dernière récompense reçue de
son vivant avant de rentrer en inde
fêter son 87e anniversaire
elles seront au coeur du bronx new york
et à l'antenne de l'ordre des
missionnaires de la charité là elle
reçoit la visite de la princesse diana
la mère des pauvres et la princesse du
peuple main dans la main unis par le
même élan charitable troublante image
que celle de ces deux femmes qui vont
bientôt disparaître et suscité une
immense ferveur populaire
[Musique]
catholique à 12 ou musulmans sont
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'indiens
à pleurer aujourd'hui mère teresa dans
l'église saint-thomas de calcutta
ils viennent malgré les pluies de la
mousson apporter quelques fleurs à celle
qui leur a témoigné temps compassion ici
même la jeune soeur agnès son véritable
prénom commence sa mission à nad c'était
en 1929 elle deviendra plus tard mère
teresa en souvenir de sainte-thérèse de
lisieux il faudra l'ordre des
missionnaires de la charité
quatre membres aujourd'hui et près de
600 astucieux chacun ici partagent la
même notion une mère c'est une mère
nous étions tous ses enfants l'épreuve
les misérables et l'épreuve elle aimait
tout le monde il n'y a aucun mot pour le
dire
une tragédie après une autre la
princesse diana est morte maintenance et
mère teresa je ne sais pas ce que vont
devenir les gens de calcutta après ça
elle est comme une déesse pour nous moi
je suis un hindou mais elle n'a pas mis
de frontières entre les religions chez f
elle les a toutes réunies pour n'en
faire qu'une
c'est sa plus grande réalisation
un chrétien pouvait l'approcher un
hindous et musulmans
quelle que soit sa religion chacun
pouvait la voir c'est ce qu' il y a de
plus important pour nous elle est l
incarnation de la presse de calcutta
associe aujourd'hui la mort de mère
teresa et celle de lady diana
les deux maires unissent le monde dans
le chagrin nitot en titre les
funérailles auront lieu samedi elles ont
été retardé pour permettre à de
nombreuses personnalités internationales
d'y assister
sur le camion kaki tractant le
catafalque un face-à-face étonnant ce
matin dans les rues de calcutta
entre les petites soeurs des
missionnaires de la charité et les
soldats de l'armée indienne
des funérailles nationales en effet pour
la somme des pauvres dans l'enceinte du
stade mais hadji toutes les religions
sont représentées pour la célébration de
cette cérémonie funèbre protestants
hindous musulmans sikhs ou bouddhistes
unis dans un même hommage à la
religieuse catholique que l'archevêque
de canterbury
li efira d'ange de la paix règne
président épouses de chefs d'état
ministre assistent à ces obsèques du
prix nobel de la paix qui a consacré sa
vie comme le rappellera les preuves aux
damnés de la terre
la france était représentée par
bernadette chirac et bernard kouchner
les états unis par hillary clinton le
représentant du pape le cardinal angelo
sodano a lu un hommage de jean paul ii à
la petites soeurs des pauvres qui a
allumé dans ce monde je cite une pomme
d'amour offrons des déshérités une
orpheline un lépreux et un aveugle à
leur madone de calcutta soeur nirmala
qui a pris la succession de mère teresa
à la tête des missionnaires de la
charité a demandé à l'assemblée de prier
pour que l'ordre garde la même
détermination dans son combat pour les
pauvres
mon action n'est qu'une goutte d'eau
dans l'océan disait mère teresa
mais ce sont les gouttes d'eau qui
forment un océan dépôt de couronnes au
nom de la france par bernadette chirac
et bernard kouchner au pied du cercueil
blanc recouvert du drapeau indien
safran blanc et vert autre image
surprenante de ses obsèques
les religieuses qui accompagne mère
teresa jusqu'à sa dernière demeure au
son de la cornemuse
c'est à l'intérieur de la maison de la
mer comme on surnomme le siège de la
congrégation des missionnaires de la
charité que mère teresa a été inhumé les
soldats d'élite de l'armée indienne lui
ont rendu les honneurs par quatre salles
de 32 coupe-feu 4 clairon ont ensuite
sonné l'adieu aux armes marquant la fin
de cette cérémonie
[Musique]